riguardo a cicchetti
oggi nuova è che i promo dove tutto
parla dei pop hit signati gratis bari
gameplay ma abbiamo innanzitutto una
sala in su per voi è per questo che ho
questo dato in mano vi ricordate in
quale altro video vi ho usato questo
dato vediamo chi se lo ricorda il pesce
salato quello di soci che vive in vita
le si no il novero delle cose di cui
dovrete mettervi pià 3 2 1
mi piace in più facciamo il gioco di mi
piace l'ultima cifra del vostro mi piace
corrisponde anche pop hit 7 per essere
in tema pop hit quindi qua a fianco
vedrete tutti i pop hit e potrete
scoprire che pupi tastiere no
quindi oggi proveremo vari giochi rho
blog su pop intenzioni perché pruno pure
scambieremo hip hop
prendete i pop corn prima di iniziare
però voglio parlarvi di un fantastico
gioco guardate che se ne importa è un
gioco in cui puoi iniziare un'avventura
magica nel continente di the date
inglesi mibac tuo fratello è stato
catturato devi trovare un modo per
riportarlo indietro nel gioco può
interagire con l'ambiente e risolvendo
pari rompicapo o combattendo contro dei
nemici con le sue armi o utilizzando
diversi elementi per sconfiggerli il
combattimento è comunque molto semplice
e se invece sei più pacifista poi
arrampicarti nuotare pescare e persino
volare planando con le ali puoi
esplorare le diverse regioni ognuna con
le sue caratteristiche con paesaggi
mozzafiato e la possibilità di giocare
con i tuoi amici che non massimo di 4
sarà molto facile immergerti in questo
magico mondo ma per sviluppare il pieno
potenziale della sua squadra dovrai
padroneggiare i sette diversi poteri che
attendono di essere scoperti negli
aggiornamenti della versione
punto 1 troverai una nuova mappa nuove
armi una nuova storia e nuovi mostri e
la parte più importante
tre nuovi personaggi giocabili
raven e shogun salgono miyako comi e
chiuso sarà sono davvero bellissimi e
ognuno di loro è unico ci sono più di
trenta personaggi al momento è che i
fini infatti sta aggiungendo nuovi
fantastici contenute intervalli di
qualche settimana
non perderti il primo anniversario del
gioco sarà il più grande evento di
sempre infatti per l'occasione ci
saranno vari ricompense gratuite è un
concerto online assieme a tanto altro
scarica subito games l'impact per
iniziare la tua avventura è gratuito e
disponibile per ios android pc e console
ps cliccare il link e descrizione per
caricarlo subito mi raccomando applicare
voi nel ii che in descrizione per
scaricare il gioco fatevi sua personale
qual è il vostro profumo sopprimendo giù
nei commenti e ora avrete bocca armate
nei giovani è iniziato nella prima
escape room io una maglietta simile
questa vediamo niente sindaco a quello
dei fenomeni
questa è una mega ma che è successo
giocatore
[Musica]
ma tipo pinciana se passiamo qua
scoppiano liti esempio tutti
loro paese dove montano di quota e
andiamo meglio chi riuscirà a finire
questi primati
aspetta tanto lo sai che miss progetti
con la sinistra se l'era vitale in
queste prime due tanto che non gioco
quindi sicura si sfracella devono remo
vedremo intanto
si guarda solo c'è alito vitale secondo
voi che
pure io
fate i no vado io prima e guarda un
giorno spinto vado io
primo
aiuto aiuto prima devo superare vitale
serio questo infonde di patria se
qualcuno fa ha
superato tutti ragionano e raggiungo
vitale del presena per colpa tua se la
vendita eco vitale dove fra sella
[Musica]
giorgia ma ho un oggetto qua vediamo in
carino posso prendere un po pt mauri
starà in testa leggera javito leila
giuridici invece queste sono le tre i
tre ponti e mi avete insegnato che basta
fare così e vedere in quali passa
attraverso sembra che il mio nome dei
viola non vitali per il montaggio sto
per raggiungere il mega popoli sediamo
gas gigante ormai capitale mio sito
raggiungermi preghiamo c
no ma bisogna evitare inquadrati donna
vitale con la diagnosi è raggiunta oggi
altra fattispecie è vita dei due sono
fido c'è stata sì no no no non lo
sapremo vita possono capitare dove beta
brigate se bisogna sempre saltare vivo
ma questi sono i più del gioco di
scambio pop hit quindi ne voglio più pop
hit bello tutto tema questo hanno capito
che vorrai ora raggiungendo freghiamo
c'è il ritardo ma ho capito come
funziona in questo momento ci sono
tantissimi genitori che stanno giocando
per noi però quanti sono 26 siamo vicini
no dovete
vitalizzare in mano l'altro mi sto
facendo portare a spasso da qualcuno
uccide i
germi e troppo difficile qua
[Musica]
ora vengo a prenderti 70 in testa no
guarda sui fatti
cerchiamo di buttare giù vita non vi
sono più veloce
devo arrivare prima io di vita quindi
con la molla si può saltare ancora di
più devo vedere come funziona una molla
no no non uscivo la capitale dove dove
abita le votiamo legge però proviamo
ma guarda che figo con la molla
piano piano piano qua bisogna mantenere
l'equilibrio
se vengo buttarti giorni di maggio sia
superata ormai
bisogna fare
aiuto dopo scapparvi voluto vedere come
tale aiuto sbrighiamoci tanto decaduta
in maniera più ha superato anna vitale
pa dietro sei pronto abbiamo fatto
guarda che adesso che arrivo lì ti butto
giù e danti azzardare invece ne può
parlare poi guarda chi c'è
sull'autotrasporto metalliche same time
lei sì ma io salvato aver superato l'ho
superato non sto avvicinando vitale
eccolo lì speriamo che accada ha nel
frattempo c'è una giocatrice qualche mi
sto sempre aspettando vuole farmi
compagnia o corte voglia di vendermi da
abitare dai manca poco ti vedo
vincerò io vincerà vitale certo io
adesso non mi ricorda tonellato devo
andare ecco vitale io sono sempre avanti
ma vitale mi ha superato
accaduto anzi su questa seduta a
cosa avevo selezionato la molla francese
un po pizzicate prenderò io dovrei bravo
anche se caduta è capitale la giudica
abbiamo superato è uno perché tra un pò
difficile
e ancora per poco lo sarai è capitato a
penserei a
vedremo ma vicinissimo il compito cig
anche di sono forse sono arrivare a
quello blu
vediamo che bello questo papi trovò no
ai popoli avvio scoppiavo
velocissimamente doppi tardi abbiamo
sempre in testa però ecco vita
al bloccaggio no
no a 130 questi vincerò appunto usa deve
tenere l'equilibrio ma insomma non
vogliate avvicinare evitare quello che
non è riuscito a raggiungerti
superato si sa che sto raggiungendo nata
e ancora la pratica più avanti di te mi
ha fatto cadere giù a sé che tutto pure
tu 20 st io sono solo testa di vitale
orrore sila lui da
poche rivali sulla mia testa si trascina
giù è difficilissima questa parte allora
io provo con la molla per un botto vi
sono inc reali
guardate un altro po bitonci cutter dove
dovevamo avvicinando alla fine il
gigante verde e matri 6 lei viva sono
molto biavati digitale un questa visto
quel puntino la rom è sfracellato questo
è molto difficile
le fortune ormai siamo bravi nel parkour
no blocks più o meno tran evitare prende
vita la prima volta
vediamo tutto mancassero quasi no sono
super in alto devo assolutamente
prendere i mezzi di questo parkour
perché è lunghissimo e difficile sapete
che io colleziono i badge mi dispiace
quando non molto più avanti di te io sto
capendo sempre invece un'altra pop hit
gigante ci stiamo avvicinando alla fine
forse l'ultimo compito gigante sarà
quello lì arcobaleno diamo un
arriva un altro pacchetto cinema no
il vantaggio è stato a livello
stressante entrambe se vi va la vita
mirare animale io sono alimento 50
sporco vorrei vincere io questa volta
lo riporta sopra indietro perché questa
parte qui caldo sempre che i ragazzi
allora è passata di paura ora perché
abbiamo gravarlo questo parkour azioni
nome però ce l'abbiamo fatto abbiamo
fatto sono livelli un nuovo anta 5
quindi la fine dobbiamo farla combo è
vitale abbandonato
perché diventato troppo lunghi troppo
difficile non si possa credere cassa in
tour i veli per fare con roberto che non
abbiamo mai fatto un far coraggio
vedo l'ora di vedere come sarà il badge
finale perché per avere in quest'altro
tutto barbati cosa
abbiamo con la molla bravo
bravo mancano solo quattro ribelli non
ci posso credere via il vento questo nel
98 questi super di fino e io mi sono
bloccato su un altro bisogna
semplicemente buttarsi salire su vedi
tav
alta invece potevano possa stare sempre
con me
un altro bobby tra ecco
a che livello sono certo ce l'ho fatta
presiedendo che cosa che cosa devo fare
una scoppiato tifo pezzo più bello da
meglio mezzo da the mist obitorio che la
legge mi merito al mezzo ha fatto certo
livello non sarebbero hanno già dato
quello che
vediamo è vero sì sì sì sì guardo
mazzali limitiamo saliamo e adesso
prendila il pop hit gigante di among us
magari e spero che me lo faccia freddo
più veloce vedere se è meglio se prendi
ma più il salto
eccolo qua i buoni giudicate
di facciata gialla
sto arrivando poi penso gigante io ti
prendono
dove non sono riuscita sempre il gigante
però ho preso il badge della reggina
completa verità
proprio così quando lo zoom ma dobbiamo
cambiare i politici sono un sacco di
giocatori questi sono tutti i tabelloni
un uomo in tantissimi vi faccio vedere i
miei capito questo e poi ho questo
aumento è uguale e questo si sa noi
dicevamo nolenti io vado in questo
tabellone e vediamo se arriva qualcuno
per cambiare ma non a un idolo è
arrivato tu vai ti piace questo metto il
mio bobbit qua vediamo io vedo questo
arcobaleno accetto aggiungeva quindi ora
posso prenderlo è che venire un po
fitarco balena è bruttissimo ma la
giusta presi a molti quadri con qualcuno
per scambiare il mio copit blu buttiamo
io lo metto qui vediamo se arriva
qualcuno e barreto
basha che guarda cecchetti
ei ladri
di moretti ei ma come è possibile che si
possono rubare hip hop italiano tra
problemi come col cappello da polpo kiss
ha ammesso rinaldi ha fame perché non
aver voluto giocare un dentista bus
della norma da un aneddoto che possono
ormai pop e omofobe riproviamo qua
vediamo un po io non lo lascia il pop
hit finché non arriva qualcuno
altrimenti me lo rubano va bene
scambiamo i convitati quale io questo
cosa mi dai lascio questo pd bluetooth
di più ne voglia di buon occhio di più e
allora dico questo
ok non certo piaciute reso ma accetto
perché voglio scappare da qua bene ora
un po più di po pt attimo trade mi sa
che sono andato meglio io perché questo
è un po più costoso
vediamo ti arriva qualcuno per cambiare
vediamo in unico fit che ho preso con me
sono rivero ha fatto che carini questo
arcobaleno infatti non a scambi vediamo
che quel perché non è che dalla data
sono stato io quell'arcobaleno prezzi in
questo gioco e siamo solo io e vitale io
aspetto
protetta cose che
contano ma si deve caricare video che ti
faccio vedere il mio amico gatto amico
gatto si
fa un po paura questa che sembra nata
per ora qua velino amico gatto
gigantesco adesso per male nel tuo
sembra un mostro e questi sono i pochi i
beni dovresti fare questi giganti possa
servirsi sopra anche se sono attese
da quindi è successo qualcosa di strano
sono esplosi ma possa prenderli no che
belli questi politici fanti e piano
l'ho preso ho preso un po più
darò la mano ma non si comprenderà di
quel progetto va bellissimo del grigio è
sparita io sono qui le sto perdendo
acustic o vado a prendere quelli giganti
e visto il fiato che le norme che
signora che può vederlo bene non è più
tanto horror dai pochi carini
guardate la juke e creando quel posto
dove è vitale
ecco la lazio sta andando anche noi per
tosi ma no vabbè faccio un muro
invisibile
non riesco andare avanti vado non aiuta
devo prendere i nomi sbagliato strada
tanto non riuscirei mai a trasportato
sua casa al big antica right hand
andiamo tutti e due no non si può
prendere o non è arrivata ma per niente
mourinho salirci sopra
vabbè andiamo in seguito
i nomi seguire ciò che proprio strano
infatti esistiamo sono il piccolo che
non c'era nessuno facebook è bello
stesso volto faccia a prenderli per
scambiare male che forse non si
scambiano forse erano solo con gli altri
si sono scambiate dorato
allora dobbiamo tornare ascoltavo lo
penso perché questi non si possono
prendere e che bello questo pop hit al
contrario io ti offro questo
siccome faccio prendere questo compito
gigante ma è sparito
la mamma
credo
si debba tutto non aver fornito
proprio no perché
amava troppo divertente che sta bene una
ma io te lo vorrei lasciare qui promesso
come lasciarlo provo prenderlo adesso
passando per un cappello di dell'italia
nei tagli dei
capi troppo divertente che cosa offre
vostro questo
[Musica]
vitale nominare un po bitri armato
sciami fatto questo che questa maglietta
gettata aspetta forse adesso adesso
vediamo
dentro al pop in via che è stato
divertente vedere vita
eva è stato il vostro lesotho preferite
di questi treni per me il primo il
parkour
lunghissimo 100 livelli e poi questa
stato più divertente prevede di rotolare
anche se non funziona di contro cui il
perito quale stato scrivetelo nei
commenti vi ricorda di scaricare il
gioco che scimmie impact john e la
descrizione cliccate nel link iniziate
la vostra avventura e alla vita qualcosa
cellino e poi cliccare perché dei nostri
altri video cliccate su quella che
preferite
ciao